Part B four zero is less than T is less
than one there is a point on the curve
at which the line tangent to the curve
has a slope of two the line tangent to
the curve has a slope of two at what
time is the object at that point so the
slope of the tangent line is two that
means that the rate of change of Y with
respect to X is equal to two
well they don't go directly give us the
derivative of Y with respect to X but
they do give us the derivative of X with
respect to T that's the derivative of X
with respect to T and they give us the
derivative of Y with respect to T the X
component of the velocity function is
the rate of change of X with respect to
time and the y component of the velocity
function is the rate of change of Y with
respect to time and using those two we
can figure out the rate of change of Y
with respect to X if you were to take
the derivative of Y with respect to T
and divide it by the derivative of X
with respect to T derivative of X with
respect to T well if you if you for the
sake of of I guess conceptually
understanding it if you view the
differentials the way that you would
view traditional numbers and fractions
well the DTS would cancel out and you'd
be left with dy divided by DX or a
little bit more formally you could go to
the chain rule and you'd say all right
the derivative of Y with respect to T is
equal to the derivative of Y with
respect to x times the derivative of X
with respect to T this comes straight
out of the chain rule so this is the
chain rule right over here that is the
chain rule and then if you divide both
sides by the derivative of X with
respect to T you're going to get that
original expression right over here well
how is this useful well we know it the
derivative of Y with respect to T is we
know the derivative of X with respect to
t is we know them as functions of T and
then we can set them equal to two and
then use our calculators to solve for T
so let's do that
the derivative of Y with respect to T
that is e to the point 5t
so we have e to the 0.5 T and then we
divide it by the derivative of X with
respect to T so that's going to be the X
component of the velocity function so
cosine of T squared and so this is the
derivative of Y with respect to X and we
need to figure out at what T does this
equal to 2 or if we or if we want to
simplify this and in our calculator we
need to set this up so it's it's some
expression you know some function of X
is equal to 0 so let me let me rearrange
this equation so I have a bunch of
things equaling equaling 0
let's see I could just subtract 2 from
both sides or actually what I could do
is I could multiply both sides times
cosine of T squared and so I'll have e
to the 0.5 T is equal to 2 cosine of T
squared and then I can subtract this
from both sides and I will get e to the
0.5 t minus 2 cosine of T squared is
equal to 0 and now I could use the
solver on my calculator to figure this
out so let's get the calculator out and
let's go to math whoops let me make sure
it's on so a math and then go all the
way down to the solver so select that so
my equation is zero is equal to so I'm
going to say e to the 0.5 and the
variable that going to solve for I'm
going to use X instead of T the same
thing I'll get the same answer e to the
0.5 X all right and then I'm going to
have minus 2 times cosine of x squared
is equal to 0 all right so there you
have it 0 is equal to e to the 0.5 X
minus 2 cosine of x squared
click enter and then we put our initial
guess and they tell us that 40 is
between 0 and 1 so maybe a good guess
would be right in between so let's put
point 5 there and then we press alpha at
least on this calculator and then you
see that little blue solve there that
will actually solve it let it munch on
it for a little bit and I get T is equal
to zero point eight four zero zero point
eight four is zero so T so T is
approximately zero point eight four zero
and we are done